YouTube has been caught despite all of
its claims that its cleaning up its
algorithm actively promoting videos
containing completely anti scientific
climate change denial this is based on a
new report from avaaz which I'm going to
tell you about in a second many of you
know that over the last 18 months our
YouTube channel has been absolutely
crushed by YouTube's recommended video
algorithm and its monetization algorithm
I'll have updated numbers for you from
20 to 1 2019 in total later this week or
early next week
I'm not going to retell the full details
of the story right now but the gist of
it is that in late 2018 YouTube started
promoting so-called
authoritative content over fringe
content and we were wrapped up in that
what Dave they've done effectively is
recommend corporate legacy YouTube
channels like CNN MSNBC and Fox News's
YouTube channels over independent
channels like ours and it has heard us
hugely I told you a couple of months ago
that I believed we were losing about 2
to 3 million views per month since early
2019 but it turns out that it's actually
even worse than that if you go back to
February of 2017 we got more than 6
million views just from YouTube's
recommendations that's not our whole
channel that's just from the
recommendations in December of 2019 it
was 600,000 that is a literal decimation
of our recommended views the shortfall
is as much as five and a half million
views in a month this is destroying the
channel I truly when I see those numbers
it's so disheartening and crushing to
see it given what we have done over the
last several years to be a bigger and
bigger part of the discussion on YouTube
and to see our recommendations shrink to
barely 10 percent of what they once were
and then we find out because of this
report that Avaaz puts out they look up
5,000 videos which come up when you
search terms climate change global
warming and related terms and then they
look at 5,000 videos and
they checked which videos is YouTube
recommending when you are watching those
videos right if you search for climate
change and watch a video what is YouTube
then suggest that you watch in the up
next bar of videos that shows up next to
or below the video you're watching
depending on whether you're on mobile or
on a computer depending on which search
term you used anywhere from 8 to 21
percent of the videos that YouTube
recommended you watch next included
climate science denial of different
kinds 21% is more than 1 out of 5 now if
YouTube said we're not taking any
position on promoting authoritative
content over fringe reliable content
over conspiracies
I'd say fine they're not taking a
position their algorithm is not trying
to promote authoritative over fringe
content and there's some climate science
denial stuff that is shown up but
YouTube says we are going to promote
authoritative stuff over fringe content
and conspiracy content and it costs our
channel to three five and a half million
views per month but supposedly it's
worth it right because they're not
promoting BS conspiracies and fringe
content and yet in some cases one out of
five climate change recommendations are
for climate science denial conspiracy
videos now you might wonder why is the
recommendation algorithm so important
there are so many ways people find
videos things shared on social media
their subscriptions feed direct searches
the up next feature meaning this
recommendations algorithm dictates 70%
of what people are watching on YouTube
and it is costing us anywhere from two
to three up to five and a half million
views per month and meanwhile
anti-science climate denial
nonsense is still being suggested by
YouTube we have to fight this and
unfortunately we probably can't get
YouTube to change its algorithm I am
sending all of this data to my YouTube
rep seeing what they can do what we can
do is directly support channels we value
to ensure that they're not tied to
YouTube ad revenue
I know I've said it before that's that's
what we have to do for us it's really
easy membership and patreon grab a
membership on our website we've got a
discount code that is 66% off that code
is 20/20 now okay I don't care at what
financial level you're involved even if
it's two bucks a month using the code
20/20 now do it you can also just throw
a dollar or two our way on patreon at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
these are small amounts of money in some
cases if you're doing a dollar a month
it's almost like a micro payment but it
adds up when thousands of you do it so
please consider it the situation is dire
we are rapidly heading into an
incredibly important election with the
YouTube recommendations algorithm not
recommending independent channels like
ours I'll have a full report about the
data later this week or early next I
know that the David Pakman show audience
is full of curious and creative people
who love learning new things and
bettering themselves and that's why I'm
so excited to tell you about one of our
sponsors Skillshare the vibrant online
learning community that offers thousands
of classes on almost any topic you can
imagine and you'll get full access to
the entire library of classes for two
entire months free when you go to david
pakman.com slash skill all of the
classes are taught by experts in their
fields they've got classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design bookkeeping marketing personal
productivity doesn't even scratch the
surface I recently took a class about
photography if anybody follows me on
instagram you know that my photography
skills leave much to be desired and it
was great I got so much out of it and
hopefully you will see the fruits of me
taking that class reflected in my
Instagram pictures sooner than later
they have classes for every skill level
whether you're wanting to get better at
something you already have experience
with you want to learn something totally
new to you you set your own pace classes
are usually less than an hour long
they're divided up into bite-size
segments so you can easily fit them into
your schedule make 2020 a year where you
explore new skills deep in existing
passion
get lost in creativity Skillshare really
makes it easier than ever
Skillshare memberships are less than ten
bucks a month and that gives you access
to the thousands of classes they offer
but everybody in the David Pakman show
audience gets a Skillshare membership
totally free for two whole months just
go to david pakman.com slash skill
that's david pakman.com slash s ki ll